[Music]
well hi everybody thank you so much for
joining us today happy monday
welcome to the rstudio enterprise
community meetup i'm rachel i'm calling
in from boston today
i would love to introduce our speaker
maravirov lifker co-founder and ceo of
data society
marav will share with us some lessons in
communicating the value of data science
and bridging the gap between teams
well thank you so much for for joining
let me go ahead and actually
share my screen here so you can all see
what i'm seeing um this is meant to be
informal as rachel said uh you know
this is really really fun for me to do
these types of presentations to be able
to share the best practices that we've
learned
and then um you know hear from you and
hear
what else you're interested in so don't
be shy with questions um
that's exactly why i'm here
all right uh so hopefully you can all
see
my screen
looks good looks good okay great
so i like to call this presentation talk
data to me because i'm a nerd and i like
puns
um but really the subtext here is
communicating the value of data so i'll
give you a bit of a history of
myself and talk um a little bit about
what i do before i do that just wanted
to let everyone know
presentation best practices so i like to
have this beginning of each one just as
a gentle reminder
um you know we want this group to be
interactive you're all here to get value
and to learn something new
so just silence alerts
from emails cell phone slacks text
messages
and then participate in discussions like
if you have some discussion questions so
i want this to be interactive this is
really your time to be able to learn
what you want to learn and i want to
make sure that everybody
um can really walk away with something
concrete
so
as rachel said i'm the ceo and
co-founder of data society just to give
you an idea of who we are on the company
that i helped start back in 2014. i'm
actually
did not start in the data science field
so my background is in education
i started as a
public school teacher in new york city
teaching elementary special education
for a number of years
and that's where my passion is it's
really an education it's imp in
empowering individuals and providing
skills for them to really supercharge
what they're able to do and maximize
their impact and that's really what we
do at data society where we just help
professionals use data better we deliver
custom data science training programs to
organizations we also have a solution
side of the house
but over eight years we've seen a really
interesting evolution of um
of what organizations and professionals
are are looking for in data and that's
some of what we'll talk about today
and as best practices go with um with
any teaching for those who know
education we like to start out with some
objectives what are you going to walk
away with today
so an understanding of some challenges
that data professionals still face today
that you might all face today
data trends how they've shifted since
2018 2017
um we'll talk a little bit about that
and then also some concrete steps that
you can take to
better communicate the value of data
incorporate data-driven practices into
your organization
and if there's something here that's on
this list that you're not seeing that
you want to walk away with
let me know in the chat or you can also
put that in slido i want to leave plenty
of time for questions and discussions at
the end to make sure that again we're
answering the questions that you have
all right and with that there is a
survey link here
um
actually let me see if i can
post that in the chat this is the survey
this is what i like to call the
frustrated data scientist survey if you
are a data professional um you might
face some frustration
and we want to learn more about that
um because that's some of what i'll be
talking about today so if you have a few
minutes um this is the only time i'll
say yeah feel free to open another
window if you want to fill out the
survey you're more than welcome to we'll
learn a little bit more about that
all right okay let's turn back time 2018
folks
what was happening in 2018 uh well
those don't remember black panther came
out that was a pretty big hit
um
people were eating tide pods
does anybody else remember that in the
u.s this was this might have been only
an american thing really um where there
was something called the tide pod
challenge and
um it didn't end very well but uh that's
just
what it was um
beyonce made history in coachella this
is also when time's up movement started
k-pop started game popularity kind of
all over the globe harry married megan
they were also still royals like there
was a lot of stuff happening in 2018 and
it might feel
away now given where we were at the
moment but that was the
culture back then
and
specific to data science
when we think about what did the field
look like back then there were a few
things that were happening at the time
so the first one is that there was
more of a focus on some data pipelines
starting to shift you know apis were
becoming very popular because people
just heard that they were being used a
lot
there were some advances in nlp as well
as deep learning i believe the bert
model paper came out during that time
and there's also an increased demand on
model interpretation so
as data was growing what i would say is
more people were realizing oh we don't
really understand this and just to give
you an idea
when we started
um
when we started in 2014 we would go to
meetings with potential clients and
partners
and we would say you know we teach like
our programming for example and we got
the question no kidding we've got the
question oh why is it called r why
didn't you call it s like why didn't you
call it something else if we say python
programs oh why is it called python
right so really if we remember all the
way back in 2014 like
open source languages were not really
well known outside of the data community
statistician community fast forward to
2018 it became a lot more popular
but what we found is that a lot of
data professionals who worked with felt
just really
frustrated and stuck typically they were
maybe the only person in the
organization that knew how to use one of
these tools
they got a lot of nonsensical requests
they spent most of their time explaining
data digging around in data
using excel um
you know so
there's
there was a lot of that happening and
one of the things we wanted to find out
is okay um well how can we better help
people
so back in 2018 uh we were a pretty
small
company pretty small community
so i just posted something on medium
said why we're giving away data science
training materials for free
um because i built a survey that base
that
kind of asked some of these questions to
understand what the pain points were
and at the end of the survey i'd be able
to compile the results take some of
those trends and then be able to
actually build a toolkit
that could address some of these pain
points so this is what the survey looked
like this is back in our old branding
i left that survey up for
a month
ish
we ended up getting almost 200 responses
which for us was great at the time like
i said we're a small company um you know
we're we're bootstrapped so we didn't
have a bc or anything like that
and then i took that
we um then posted the results on medium
again and then we were able to
send out a toolkit that was really
focused for data professionals who
felt frustrated felt as though they were
stuck felt as they couldn't communicate
insights correctly and i have a really
terrible joke um
that'll tell you now which is you know
if um a data scientist finds a new
insight but nobody around her
understands it does it matter right and
like sadly the answer is no it's kind of
a sad joke but i appreciate it for
anybody who gave me the pity laugh while
you were on mute so thank you
um
and we we know the value of
we everybody i think on this call
understands the value of data
and so for us we felt like it was such a
missed opportunity and a lot of lost
resources to have such talented people
working on insights that at the end of
the day would never be
implemented
and so the results that we found
at the time this was again this was
2018.
leadership non-data colleagues they
didn't really understand what data could
do
um
about 30 of data professionals time was
spent explaining results
so imagine in 40
hours in a 48-hour week you're spending
10 to 15 hours of that literally just
telling other people about the work that
you're doing
and we got a lot of um
magic
uh comments in our open-ended section
where a lot of people said yeah my boss
feels like what i do is magic like i
just click a button
magic happens right
um
and so those were the types of trends
that we were seeing
so based on that
we developed a toolkit and what does
toolkit include so there are kind of
three components to it
um
toolkit we call it the data science
communicator toolkit and what it's meant
to do is to help facilitate a
conversation between you the data
professional and people around you who
might not understand data
so the first thing is
marketing right um so the toolkit comes
with a presentation it comes with a
script and it also comes with sample
email templates
that can that you can really just copy
and paste and send out you know putting
in what whatever you want
um so the email template you saw first
this is an example of the script
um and then we have a slide deck as well
that's based off of the topics that
we've got created the most frustration
so when we're thinking about what did
that presentation actually include it
was a lot of what data science can do
and can't do
um talking about some ethics behind data
science
focusing specifically on how difficult
it is to collect data
um right it's not all of a push of the
button to start facilitating the
communication and actually kind of
building a common vocabulary right
um
and that was the purpose behind it so we
sent the toolkit out got some great
responses back
it still exists um
it's still around and you can absolutely
access it and i think rachel i think
it's still on the
the champion page if i'm not mistaken
yes it is i will share that in the chat
too i'll put in a plug for that if you
just want to take a look at what it was
um
and
you know come 2022
and things are a little bit different
right
uh so first of all covet happened that
was obviously a huge huge shift
um people are working more remotely
there's a ton more data that exists
even from 2018 to today
alongside there's really been yeah an
increased focus of data everywhere right
so if you have a fitbit which i have um
as well if you have an apple watch if
you take bikes in the city or any type
of um individual transportation like the
scooters
people can track movements within a city
um
so you're all the sensing again such an
influx of individual information on top
of the fact that especially with the
coveted pandemic hey data actually
became i mean it was always there were
some cases where it was life or death
but now there were a lot of cases where
that's true right if people if health um
agencies weren't sharing information
with each other we're really talking
about lives that were at stake
so covid plus increase of data
everywhere and then in the past few
years one of the shifts that we've seen
is a focus for more companies and more
organizations to
become data driven so what what i would
say is in our earlier years
um
even through 2018 and 2019
training programs were focused on
specific technical skills right so just
intro programming machine learning
techniques neural networks text mining
but these were folks that already had
essentially a background of data there
was some excel training power bi tableau
as well but it wasn't as prominent
in the past few years we've seen a lot
more of a demand for almost like a
holistic data academy continuous
learning where now there's a mandate
coming from
from senior leadership and i don't know
if you've seen this where you are where
they're determined to become a data
literate organization so now it's not
just the data scientist but it's
literally everybody within the
organization needs to have at least a
basic understanding of what data does
how to use it
how to manage it right we're seeing an
increase in data governance
so if you work
if you work in any type of a healthcare
company or finance you probably have
already had a lot of these regulations
in place
if you don't you're probably going to
see a lot more of that so obviously
europe passed gdpr
and that was a really really big shift
in terms of how we think about data i
know california also passed i believe
it's called the cpaa
similar to the gdpr about giving
ownership back to individuals so
ownership of data back to individuals
so in addition to these trends another
trend that we're seeing is okay well now
everybody needs to understand data
compliance data ethics um you need to
understand data governance how to manage
that appropriately and that requires a
level of knowledge that some people
don't have
so
um
on the back of all of these trends we
thought okay
well
it's been about four years um let's
check in with the people
that we
you know that we saw a little while ago
right like what's happening now what are
they seeing in space
so i'm gonna caveat this with uh we
released the updated survey a few weeks
ago
um and we have about 40 responses at my
last check so the the number of
responses is a little bit lower which i
encourage everybody if you have an
opportunity to take it please do
that'll just help us better understand
where we are today
but even so we're finding some insights
and some shifts that i wanted to share
with you so these are the never before
seen released results
of the updated survey
and in addition to that
we're going to be updating the tool kit
accordingly to again really just help
people communicate better with the
organization
so one of the biggest shifts that we saw
from from 2018 to today
and we by the way over time we've
collected almost 400 responses so now we
have sample size of
400 versus about
40. so just wanted to put that
disclaimer out there we're all numbers
people
but
there was a shift in terms of what
data professionals wish that their
management and leadership knew which is
it went from
top issue was what data science can and
cannot do was that was what was
identified in 2018.
in 2020 is actually flipped with the
second place one which is how data
science can actually impact the company
and everything else actually looks to be
about the same
people are still feeling like nobody
understands how much time it takes
what different data science methods do
what different tools do
and to me what this says is
okay since 2018 more people understand
what data science is
almost as a concept if that makes sense
but um
people still don't really understand the
applications behind it
and how it can be used
so i thought that was a pretty
interesting shift
um
you know beyond that
do you think your organization is using
data effectively
same proportion of people said yes
versus no i was hoping that the
proportion would be a little bit more
even but we're looking at about 35 to 65
percent who said no
so it's clear that at least in terms of
the data professional world there's a
lot of work left to be done
people understand that data is important
but maybe they're still not leveraging
it effectively
some other some other trends here
you know so some of the questions that
we asked what are some of the biggest
changes that other people have seen an
increased demand
for data related roles so we all know
hiring has had some ups and downs
especially this year but in general data
roles still remain pretty high in demand
um and now there's less of a lone data
scientist
um
like in existence now what we're seeing
is that there's more people that are
joining teams of data professionals so
that's also a shift that we're seeing
um
increased amounts of training more
investment in data tools
we're the top three there and then some
of the biggest challenges
and this is actually mirrors very much
what we see as well
putting work into scalable production
again building those pipelines so i know
that ml ops has become
a really popular topic we actually
developed our own program for it last
year because we saw the demand for it
people can build algorithms but now it's
a question of how do you operationalize
it how do you scale it
getting access to the data that you need
again that's a pretty tough challenge
for people
still see that
and communicating data effectively with
my colleagues so those were the top
three challenges that people are still
seeing
you know what i would say is
putting work into scalable production is
less of something that we saw in 2018
it's definitely something we're seeing a
lot more today and so i'm curious to
hear
um about your feedback i see
lisa said she feels like yes this very
much reflects what she knows
and uh jeff is feeling a little bit of
that pain of the amount of time that it
takes for data
so hopefully these
some of these pain points and maybe some
of these improvements are are speaking
to you
so
some other trends that we're seeing
and i pull these quotes directly um from
our survey we do have some open-ended
opportunities
most people still think
it's really easy to gather data
i don't know why this is something we
try to focus on with a lot of the
programs that we run which is it takes a
lot of time and a lot of patience
magic still appears even in 2022
so machine learning can't do magic right
again we had a lot of responses saying
um there were misperceptions
misconceptions about
how data analytics can be performed
and then on the other end of the
spectrum we have a situation where
people have enough knowledge to know
that it can do stuff but don't
understand the limitations right so data
science means anything is possible
because look at google
yes if we were to look at google right
if we were to look at those really high
tech organizations
it seems like they can do anything and
everything with data analytics and
machine learning
but
you know
it's easy to look at them and say they
can do all of this we can too
and it's another thing to actually take
a look and evaluate the infrastructure
that you have in place with an
organization right
how is your data stored how is it being
collected who knows how to use it right
so there's a lot of people that said my
manager thinks i can do anything
with
machine learning and in theory
that's kind of true but it's also not if
they don't have the relevant support
behind them
interestingly enough thirty percent of
time on average is still spent
explaining results i would have hoped
you know that would be a little bit less
um but you know overall what we're
seeing at least in the responses so far
and we're hoping to collect some more is
that people have a better idea of data
but they don't really understand the
nuances behind what's possible and
what's not they're having difficulty
understanding the applications
and um
that still seems to be like a big
challenge for most people
with that
i have a discussion question for you and
i'm seeing some people are already
chiming in
so i'll give folks a few minutes in the
chat
how is this similar to what you're
seeing um alternatively
are there different pieces that i'm
missing here are there other pain points
that you're seeing in your organization
um
that uh
you know i haven't addressed and feel
free you can put it in the chat if
you're feeling brave um you can always
unmute yourself and provide a verbal
comment so
um i'll give folks
a few minutes just type in and tell us
like what else are you seeing is this
accurate for you
oh there it goes i was afraid i didn't
let people uh unmute there there we go
i figured i'd say it rather than type
because i typed so much during the day
but yeah very much uh feeling that and
um i started my analytics career like 20
years ago and
then worked in academia for a while and
i'm back in industry and it just like
sort of is shocking like how
like little progress has been made or
like
maybe being in a different industry how
it's like
things are still so messy and it's just
kind of shocking
yeah absolutely thank you so much for
the comment and
you have a really interesting experience
going from industry to academia and then
back to to
industry and so
um there's so much so much advancement
in the actual field of data right but
then industry it feels as though takes a
longer time to catch up as well
um so i appreciate that perspective
thanks lisa i see laura you have your
hand raised too do you want to jump in
sure um i just wanted to expand it seems
a couple of us have a similar
issue is that our data team
um we can
provide places to start inputting data
from our fields
i work in a fundraising capacity um so
we can give
pipelines for people to start recording
various activities that they
they perform to see what leads to say a
donation
but so our leadership is saying well
we've given you ways to measure those
now why aren't you giving me the answer
when maybe our field doesn't understand
that they need to enter the data or they
have their own
shadow excel system
um and they aren't recording into our
pipeline so our pipeline doesn't
necessarily look correct
um and so you know the data team we're
like we don't want to give you this
answer that you've asked for because we
don't trust this data at all but they
said well give me the answer and we'll
worry about it later so it's kind of the
partnership of
we have to give the data back to our
field members in some sort of analytic
way so that they can see the value of
the data but when the starting point is
so poor
um we don't want to give them wrong
information so getting the non-data
people in on the value of data world
when you're starting from maybe a less
data mature situation um has been one of
our biggest challenges in in various
places
yeah and and laura i
i hear you a hundred percent we see a
lot of that and i see that trend
continuing for the foreseeable future
because it takes a while for people to
kind of figure out
to know what they don't know and then
actually be willing to learn it and then
apply it in that situation
so it's it's hard when you're starting
from a point where people might not
really understand what you're saying but
you have to be able to communicate
results in some
form right
so we've seen we've seen that across a
lot and that's a great point
as well so thank you for that
and i'm seeing a lot of people being
active in the chat which is great um a
couple of other points to make you know
i think john made a good point where um
explaining data is not always lost time
especially if you're doing it for
clients
absolutely agree
um
and maybe i need to reframe my question
a little bit because
i had in my mind you know explaining the
work that you're doing to other
colleagues which again is not
necessarily time lost
um
but if there are ways to streamline that
to make it easier
but i completely hear what you're saying
and i do think that makes sense i'm also
seeing a couple of folks saying yeah
people want to hire more data scientists
but what they really need is a data
engineer for example and there are
there's definitely a lot of job postings
that i've seen out there i'm sure you
have too
where somebody wants to hire a data
scientist um that has experience with
every tool under the sun plus like a
decade of experience in analysis
and you can tell that they're not really
sure what they're looking for
so i think that's a really interesting
point as well
like people
know that they need these folks but
don't really know how to describe their
responsibilities
so i'm loving the chat that's happening
please keep it coming
and it's kind of nice to know that
on some level we're all going through
the same thing
like nobody here is alone
so there's a lot of that as well
yeah bring making the case for cultural
change completely agree
that's a really really important one
learning how to communicate with leaders
in
having leaders actually take the
responsibility of
learning themselves
about data
that's
something that we found to be really
helpful you know we have a an executive
level workshop that we deliver that when
um
when executives take it they do feel
more confident right so just being more
confident about data and understanding
the strategy
can help them be more open so definitely
if you don't have a program like that um
or if you think that your leaders are
open to it even doing something like a
lunch and learn for them
can be really helpful
so speaking of helpful
um
don't worry lippy bring out all the
feels please feel free this is a safe
space for everyone um
so
feelings galore i encourage everybody um
to feel their feelings all the time
yes and one other thing laura just added
in there
um making a dashboard and i saw this in
some of the responses as well that
making a dashboard was the same as
doing data science
dashboards are easy for people to
understand so that's the first line of
defense um
for people who want to quote unquote do
data
and if you're trying to get your
organization into a more data-driven
mindset that's a really useful tool but
it's also important for them to
understand the difference between having
a dashboard which can be
descriptive versus something more
predictive for example
so let's talk about what we can do about
this
i'm sitting in the chat i'm hearing from
you
the pain points still exist
right
um and so what can we do to start to
shift that and in fact
um excuse me i just saw lisa
saying that she's nerd lunch
hoping that it's a casual way to
introduce data literacy concepts i love
that i think
having these types of programs
internally
really speed up the
adoption of data and the understanding
of data
and in fact
that's one of my
my pieces here right so when we're
talking about
everybody on this call you have pain
points and i recognize
that you're all working really hard
so this is not meant to be an added
burden but rather an opportunity to
think through what options could work
best for you given where you are and
given where your organization is
first thing is to find a champion or be
a champion right
um
what we found to be most effective
is finding
somebody in leadership
if you have a cto cio cdo
or anybody at this c-level who's
passionate about data who has access to
budget who has a say
having somebody from leadership saying
hey this is the direction we need to go
in here are resources for you is
incredibly powerful especially with
people who might be a little bit more
resistant to
learning about data
knowing that their leadership is
expecting it um can really help speed
that process up
along those lines
if you're feeling up to it
offering some types of data trainings to
develop a common data vocabulary empower
staff again the updated toolkit that
we'll be releasing
probably within the next couple of weeks
can be a great starting point for just a
lunch and learn
how people around you understand what
data can and cannot do help them
understand you know how they can
contribute um
and make your life easier right because
i think most people in general don't
you know they want to be able to do this
on their own they just don't know how
um
giving people time and space to be
innovative so asking others maybe other
data professionals around you hey how
are you using data
um
i think one of the most important things
this is why
i love um you know kind of the r studio
community is
um
sharing best practices especially
internal to an organization is such a
powerful resource that generally isn't
leveraged to the fullest
so finding other people in your
organization who who can do that and
starting to share
you're going to really find
a strong group of folks that will
encourage
data adoption
and will also potentially help you solve
some challenges that you're seeing in
space because they're familiar with
architecture with the tools within an
organization
um so then and that's the last one right
providing space and technology for
people to innovate or bringing in
outside resources to do the same
and i'll just put in a plug one of the
things that i do
honestly this is just something that i
do for free is i do have a
presentation that talks about what data
science can and cannot do and the whole
purpose of it is to facilitate this type
of conversation
happy to chat with you if you think
that's helpful for your organization
easy for us to set up um
a lunch and learn where i can just come
in and do that and hopefully start to to
support your efforts and facilitate that
communication
being a role model i'm sure most of you
are already doing this
um
but if you're not or if you think there
are ways to improve here are some some
suggestions as well
so
asking for
metrics or analysis behind conclusions
and reports or providing them and
showing that this is what the standard
needs to look like making sure that
you're asking and addressing powerful
questions so
um talking about what the implications
are behind insights
um
using tools and exercises to get people
out of the box you know finding ways to
connect with them that
you know will help them better
understand what you're doing
talk about what it means to make a
decision based on data i saw somebody
earlier said you know we're still at a
level where we're all trusting our gut i
saw several of those comments also in
even the updated survey responses
so it's still happening you can trust
your gut and then
see if the data verifies it you know i
would say it's not always either or um
because we don't want to discount
you know levels of experience but i
think we're at a point where those
levels of experience
need to be supplemented um by data
and then again engaging creative
thinking to drive innovation
providing a safe space so a safe space
like this one a safe space like nerd
lunch
any type of lunch and learn that you
have
even with other data professionals just
what types of crazy ideas do you have
like what would be interesting to
explore
right
um
talk about what's possible and one of
the things that i always encourage any
data professional to do is
find successful examples of data
projects within your organization so
whether it's one that you did one that
your colleague did
leadership understands projects that are
done internally
so if you can show results
they will have much more
understanding of what's possible
and they're much more likely to support
your efforts
so make sure to communicate um
with those successes
and again build that community of
practice it can start from this
community it can start from any other
internal community that you have but
that's also been a really key um piece
of success
oh i jumped ahead a little bit um
giving recognition
again if there's a successful project
like shout to the rooftops about it have
a lunch to learn about it is there a
newsletter maybe write a blurb about it
right um if you have a hackathon
um demonstrate you know what were the
three the top three most successful
outcomes from a hackathon
shedding light on that not only um
encourages leadership to look more into
data but it also encourages
them to keep doing a good job
you know people like to be recognized
for the work that they're doing and so
being able to recognize that
is incredibly important
and then don't be afraid to make
mistakes
um
you know one of the things that we do
internally is
if there's ever something that goes a
little bit differently than what we
expected whether it's on the solutions
or the training side we do debrief and
just say okay why did this happen how do
we prevent it moving forward right
there's no blame
um
and that helps people
feel comfortable innovating it also
helps people feel more comfortable
asking for help when they need it
all right
last discussion question and then i will
open it up to
any type of questions that you have
um
but you know my question to you is we
talked about some concrete things that
you yourself can do
um
you know what else have you seen be
effective um to build a data driven
environment or to help other people
understand
what you're doing in a way that's
supportive to you
awesome so lisa is saying
having upper management who support the
effort
oh eugene that's a really interesting
point stop using the word data get
specific
i like that like
what metrics are you looking at what
type of data right
and i see leanne has her hand raised
ah yeah thanks i just wanted to share
something that uh initiative that we've
been doing at the financial times where
i work and um
we as a wider data science of which iran
is a part of the wider analytics
organization and we've had a big data
democratization program which is all
around kind of putting data in the hands
of people
and as part of that we really invested
in our um
hiring in a learning and development
individual who's specialist
in data so she comes from a data
analytics background but her education
is in learning and development and it's
quite a unique
niche role quite hard to source these
types of people but that's been
fantastic because part of a role is both
in educating a lot of what we've been
talking about is that whole education of
the wider uh business community but
um it's both a push and a pull in the
sense of that
she will both uh educate kind of the
wider business about the different types
of analyses descriptive prescriptive
predictive and help them to
learn to interrogate their own
questioning about what they're trying to
find out from data so that they have
already kind of understand why they're
asking those questions and what's
actually relevant
right through to then actually helping
us become better data practitioners i
guess as well as part of her
responsibility and it's a very like
interesting dynamic and really intrigued
as to how that will work but it's been a
really lovely part of our kind of data
democratization rollout is having that
individual so definitely a champion for
that
that's that's awesome and can i ask
leanne how often does that individual
come to work with you what's the cadence
there
so it's kind of so they're 100 dedicated
to analytics unfortunately this is where
it gets into difficulty that the
business doesn't quite still understand
like they're like a lot less priority
than like other roles in our
organizations like for example they're
still a contractor um at the moment the
way that it works is that whenever i've
got so
for example
my two lead data scientists need a
career plan putting together um for them
and their teams and so i've gone to her
from like some career coaching
consultancy for for them so it's kind of
in that scenario it's very ad hoc and
then um in the kind of business faking
scenario it's very um
like strategic and very organized so
sure working with various bits of the
business whether that be btc b2b etc to
educate them around those concepts um so
in terms of our needs it's ad hoc but
she recognizes that that's like 50 of
her role so it's dependent on where kind
of the demand is
that's that's great and that's really
helpful and i agree like what i've seen
and what i've had some requests to do is
just be an outside voice that comes in
somebody who's not prone to
any any internal
um
kind of organizational behaviors just to
speak and bring in my perspective to
help support data professionals
internally
and sometimes you just need an external
voice to come in and facilitate that
conversation
um i really appreciate that and i think
that's a really interesting way to do it
as well
um so thank you for that i'm seeing some
other comments so i'm just gonna
go in here you know definitely using
words that
people can connect with
like changing analytics to informatics
um
loris the confusion of data requests and
report analysis
data is not the same thing as analysis
yep
i hear you
and then
talking
libby mentioned you know having a
manager director who's willing to say no
to things that don't make sense for the
team to work on who protects their time
i agree if you have a manager who's
supportive even if they're not
necessarily technical but they
understand what you're doing that does
make a huge difference as well because
then you have an advocate in your corner
that can also
bring the work that you're doing to the
forefront
so
i love all of these chats with that
that's the end of my formal presentation
i'll just leave this here this is my
email
it's just morav datasociety.com
i'm not burdening people with having to
spell my last name
but if you want to chat if anything that
i said resonated with you or if you're
interested in doing a lunch and learn
for your own organization just let me
know
this is what i love doing like i said my
background's in education so
i enjoy
sharing best practices sharing the
knowledge that we've
acquired over the past eight years as
we've been working on this
and really my main goal is to just
um support you in the work that you're
doing right and make sure that you have
an environment around you that
understands the value of what you bring
to the table
and um
let's do questions let's do any and all
questions
so perfect thank you there actually
aren't that many questions on slido
because i see that a lot of people are
putting comments into the chat too which
i absolutely love
but one of the questions that was on
slido was
how did you make the transition
from special education teacher into data
um yeah that's a great question so i'll
tell you that
it was a lot of serendipity um
i was in the classroom for a number of
years and i decided that i wanted to be
able to have an impact
on a larger scale
so i then spent the next um
several years working at different
educational institutions like kaplan
like the international baccalaureate
organization just really learning
everything there is to know about
education training and assessments
and
honestly i had a mutual friend who
um
was having trouble
finding out how to learn about data and
how to learn specifically actually it
was our programming
he was an analyst on wall street who
spent most of his time in excel and a
friend of his
showed him how he could automate
literally three weeks of work into an
afternoon
so
you know he saw the value of that and
then when i was in my career i also was
using some data-driven methods but i
couldn't find any resources that were
specific to me as a professional where i
could just pick it up quickly
um so we had a conversation and thought
well if we can't find what we need let's
build it
you know so it was
uh myself and then two other co-founders
and
um
and you know i said that
the best thing that happens is that we
still have a company and we build
something cool and the worst thing that
happens is that i learn a lot and
you know i did quit my job nine months
into it and i said well
i can always go find another job
and so along the way i learned data
science and i found it to be
it's really empowering i've never
programmed before
and to understand how it works
to understand um how it can be
impactful for folks
um and then building something was
really fun for me so i just love solving
challenges and this was
definitely a lot of challenges to solve
that's great i
i don't think i see other slido
questions so i do want to open it up to
broader discussion and i can stop the
recording but i had one question too
um i was curious have you ever
been in a position where
you're not able to make the case to
leadership or they're like pushing back
on you and
and what do you do in that situation
we do get a lot of pushback um
interestingly enough what i would say is
it's not always top-tier leadership
um
a lot of times it's kind of management
folks that have been doing this for a
while you don't really see a need to
change
you know there are a few points that i
bring up that i think are particularly
effective the first one is
it's not something let's say that we're
forcing you to do tomorrow right we're
not going to shift everything that
you're doing we're not saying that what
you're doing is wrong what we're doing
is showing you a different set of tools
and a different set of skills that might
make your life easier
so by alleviating the type of pressure
of being forced to implement this you're
giving people room to explore and
understand for themselves
why it's important and sometimes you
know it might not be if there's a system
that works well within your organization
you don't need more out of it
it's fine i'm not going to force
somebody to you know implement something
in r if it's working just fine in excel
right so it's important to kind of have
that mindset
i think um the second point is
and again depends on the level that
you're speaking to
it will be really really hard to stay
competitive without these skills just
period right there are organizations
that are becoming really data driven
there are organizations that are
leveraging their data very very
effectively
and that translates to increased profits
increased revenue
increased efficiency more satisfaction
increased retention of employees
and guess what if you're competing
against that organization in five years
and you don't have that same level of
skills
you're gonna be feeling it
you know and so bringing in an element
of hey here are what the best
practitioners are doing in your industry
um
and so if you're not
driving towards that
just be aware it's going to be harder to
stay competitive
you know it really is a business
necessity
and then the third one is you know
bringing
finding any type of successful project
or any type of
um
use case that will speak to that
audience
right so whenever i give my
presentations i like to pull from
different use cases
in an industry where
people can
can relate to
um
and i find that that really helps with
the light bulb moment because they start
to
understand how they could be doing
something similar
so those are three points that i would
recommend
it doesn't always work it really does
depend um
you know
where the organization is their budget
um you know if somebody's invested like
10 million dollars in a tool
um
you know they're going to want to use
that tool whether it's helpful or not
right so there are some things that are
that are harder to get around
definitely
thank you
and um
i want to stay true to what i said where
i'll i'll stop the recording so we all
can jump in the conversation too but on
that that point of finding different
industry examples i wanted to say this
in the recording um i did share the
champion site rstudio.com champion which
has a ton of different industry examples
uh grouped together so it pulls together
webinars and meetups and blog posts and
just lots of people talking about the
ways they're using data science um
so that i share that in the chat too
but
i will stop the recording here so we can
all can just like jump in and chat with
each other but to anybody watching the
recording thank you
thanks morons
[Music]